When you stop and think about where you came from,
you most likely a reminded of your mother or a street you grew up on.
But think about evolution and biology class and the animal that we are closest
to the chimp.
There were based systems that control us and these systems have been studied in
animals that date back much farther than the monkey.
In fact,
the animal which gives us insight into why base drives like status and hierarchy
are built in date back one third of a billion years.
And if you've been following Dr. Jordan Peterson,
you'll know exactly what animal I'm talking about.
Yes,
you guessed it.
The lobster,
the display of status is something that dates back thousands of years.
Let's look at the lobsters habitat.
It's a volatile place with many lobsters struggling to hunt for food and
occasionally settling for scraps that fall from the sky above.
If food wasn't enough to have to worry about shelter is the next item to
struggle over.
And because shelter is so scarce,
lobsters have to resort to the only method which,
which they know how to acquire things.
Dominance.
Now it's a fun scene that is painted in the 12 rules for life of the physical
struggle for dominance among lobsters.
However,
for the sake of time,
I'll cut to the end of a fight.
Having defined a clear winner and loser.
Now it doesn't take a physical altercation to mark a winner or a loser that is
largely governed by neuro chemistry.
The two chemicals that governed the lobsters,
mood and behavior are serotonin and October Jamine Serotonin and I've Topa mean
exist in balance.
And when Serotonin is at a higher level and October me lower the effect is very
confident.
Lobster of Mcgregor ready to fight everyone type of lobster.
Also heightened serotonin makes a lobster ready to fight and display its
dominance continuously and as long as the lobster wins,
the serotonin levels stay high.
However,
if the lobster loses,
the inverse happens and an increased level of October mean and lowered serotonin
occur leaving a very sad er sort of lobster soaking around too afraid to fight.
If a previous dominant lobster loses a fight is once dominant brain transforms
into a new subordinate brain knocking him down the hierarchy like with humans.
The spoils go to the dominant,
the prime real estate,
all the ladies and all the scrap food.
The dominance hierarchy is the other biological structure built into us and all
other animals.
Yes,
builtin.
It isn't the result of social constructs like capitalism,
communism.
It's not the military industrial complex.
It's not the patriarchy.
It's not a human creation.
The dominance hierarchy has been deeply rooted for hundreds of millions of
years.
We saw it in grained in the lobster brain and it is a permanent fact of life.
The human brain at a basic level shares a similar neuro chemistry with the
lobster.
When a human loses a battle or suffers a defeat or betrayal,
we often recoil and pull within ourselves.
If we stay down for long enough,
we become chronically depressed.
Serotonin that governs posture and fight or flight reactions in lobsters has a
similar effect in humans.
Low ranking lobsters are like low ranking human beings and that their behavior
is similar.
When levels of Serotonin are low,
low confidence,
costly.
Your stress response and being at the bottom of the hierarchy generally means
more bad things can and will happen,
less happiness,
more pain and anxiety,
more illness and a shorter lifespan and with higher levels of Serotonin.
The end verse effects occur.
Less illness,
less misery in depth,
a better income.
At an unconscious level,
your status is tracked at the root of your brain.
If you're male and your status is high,
you have preferential access to the best places to live.
The highest quality food people want to socialize and will do anything to help
you.
You have limitless opportunity for romantic and sexual contact.
If you're a female at the top,
you have access to many attractive,
creative,
reliable,
honest,
high quality men and like the dominant male,
you compete ferociously,
even piddle Asley to maintain or improve your position.
The opposite end of the diamond at the opposite end of the dominance hierarchy
is a dangerous place.
No good places to live,
if any terrible food when not starving,
poor physical and mental condition as you're a minimum romantic interest to
anyone unless they are as desperate as you are.
The part of your brain that assesses dominance,
watches how you were treated by other people.
watches how you are treated by other people,
how you are treated renders your value and assigns status.
If you were judged to have little worth,
your brain restricts serotonin.
This makes you more physically and psychologically reactive to any event that
produces emotion,
particularly negative ones.
That reactivity is needed,
where emergency is common,
constantly being alert,
burns up precious energy and physical resources.
Also,
all emergencies will be tackled loan because of the lack of quality social
network at the bottom.
You continually sacrifice what you could otherwise store for the future.
Using it up on a heightened readiness drug use and promiscuity and myriad.
Other things are used to cope with the stress that habits can present serious
problems and what does the physical,
however,
it can be labeled and mistaken as a mental illness.
The positive feedback loop that alcoholism can create can be fatal.
Imagine someone who enjoys drinking alcohol.
He has a few drinks and his blood alcohol level rises and when he stops it
plateaus and begins to fall and when his body starts to metabolize the ethanol,
he has a hangover.
Well,
most alcoholics at some point realized drinking helps fight the hangover.
However,
postponing the withdrawal long enough can be fatal when the cause of the problem
is also the cure.
Creating a positive feedback loop.
The problem can spiral out of control.
With depression,
a person feels useless and burdensome so that'd become isolated and that intern
amplifies the depression.
Social anxiety often cause from some sort of
social anxiety often caused from some type of trauma like bullying can lead a
person to avoid eye contact,
be upset,
easily be certain or indecisive and take a habitually submissive posture that's
observed by all and sometimes further exploited by adults that have remained
Billie's into adulthood.
Some people become bullied because they can't fight back.
For kids,
a six year old is no match for a nine year old.
Women tend to be less physically strong in the upper body than men.
However,
some people choose not to fight back.
The temperament of a person that's bullied is commonly compassionate and self
sacrificing and high in negative emotion and it doesn't help when they make all
sorts of noises that please the sadistic no step dad,
her crying works especially well.
People who have had tyrannical parents can become sensitive to tyranny and
overaggressive competitiveness and restricted.
They themselves all the emotions that might give rise to such things.
These people may decide that all forms of aggression,
including feelings of anger are morally wrong.
These people restrict their ability to fight back and because of their
compassionate and self sacrificing temperament,
which often turns out to be naive and exploitable,
are unable to call forth the genuinely righteous,
inappropriate,
self-protective anger necessary to defend themselves.
If you can bite,
you generally don't have too.
When integrated properly,
the ability to respond with aggression and violence decreases rather than
increases the probability that actual aggression will become necessary.
If you say no early in the cycle of oppression and mean it,
then you will limit its effect on you.
When naive people discover the capacity for anger within,
they are sometimes shocked severely.
However,
when people recognize themselves as dangerous there fear decreases.
They develop more self respect.
There is a little difference between the capacity for mayhem and destruction
integrated and the strength of character applying rule one standing up straight
with your soldiers back is made much simpler by instilling a few routines in
your life.
Routines are necessary in many aspects of life to keeping your brain functioning
properly.
Sleep is the first area that you want to address specifically when you wake up.
Also,
you want to wake up around the same time other people wake up around you.
The relevance of proper sleep patterns is easily observable.
When you see the difference between well rested and sleep deprived children
night and day.
Not only does sleep regulate your security and rhythms,
but eating does too,
so alongside waking up at the same time,
eating at the same time can be important as well.
What to eat is equally important.
High fat and high protein is preferred to simple carbs and sugars.
Unlike fat and protein rich meals,
simple carbs and sugars exacerbate existing physiological and psychological
problems and cause spikes and dips in blood sugar that people identify as rushes
and crashes.
High fat and high protein diets leave you feeling energized and more balanced
throughout the day.
If you feel like you're a loser,
maybe you are.
Maybe you aren't.
Regardless,
you don't have to be.
You may just have one bad habit or a collection of bad habits.
You may have developed bad posture.
You may have been bullied or unpopular at home or in school.
It's not necessarily appropriate.
Now,
circumstances change.
If you slump around like the defeated lobster,
people will treat you as such.
Then your brain won't produce as much serotonin which will make you less happy
and more anxious and sad.
Your probability of living in a nice place,
finding a stable,
healthy mate,
your access to high quality resources will decrease.
You will live for the present and not defer gratification and you will be more
likely to abuse drugs.
Now I'm going to read a few pages of Jordan's book.
You might object.
The bottom is real.
Being at the bottom is equally real.
Emir.
Transformation of posture is insufficient to change anything that is fixed.
If you're in the number 10 position and standing up straight and appearing
dominant might only attract the attention of those who want.
Once again to put you down and fair enough,
but standing up straight with your shoulders back is not something that is only
physical because you're not only a body,
you're a spirit,
so to speak,
a psyche as well.
Standing up physically also implies and invokes and demands.
Standing up.
Metaphysically standing up means voluntarily accepting the burden of being your
nervous system responds in an entirely different manner.
When you face the demands of life voluntarily,
you respond to a challenge.
Instead of bracing for a catastrophe,
you see the goal,
the dragon hoards instead of shrinking and terror from the all too,
real fact of the Dragon.
You stepped forward to take your place in the dominance hierarchy and occupy
your territory,
manifesting your willingness to defend,
expand,
and transform it.
That can all occur practically or symbolically as a physical or as a conceptual
reconstruction.
To stand up straight with your shoulders back is to accept the terrible
responsibility of life with eyes wide open.
It means deciding to voluntarily transformed the chaos of potential into the
realities of habitable order.
It means adopting the burden of self conscious vulnerability and accepting the
end of the unconscious paradise of childhood where finitude and mortality are
only dimly comprehended.
It means willingly undertaking the sacrifices necessary to generate a productive
and meaningful reality.
It means acting to please God in the ancient language to stand up straight with
your shoulders.
Back means building the Ark that protects the world from the flood,
guiding your people through the desert after they have escaped tyranny,
making your way away from comfortable home and country and speaking the
prophetic word to those who ignore the widows and children.
It means shouldering the cross that marks the ex,
the place where you and being intersect so terribly.
It means casting dead rigid and too tyrannical order back into the chaos in
which it was generated.
It means withstanding the ensuing uncertainty and establishing in consequence a
better,
more meaningful and more productive order.
So at 10 carefully to your posture,
quit drooping and hunching around.
Speak your mind,
puts your desires forward as if you had a right to them,
at least the same right as others walk tall and gays forthrightly ahead,
dare to be dangerous.
Encourage the Serotonin to float plentifully through the neuropathways.
Desperate for its calming influence and people,
including yourself will start to assume that you're a competent and able,
or at least they will not immediately conclude the reverse emboldened by the
positive response.
As you are now receiving,
you will begin to be less anxious.
You will then find it easier to pay attention to the subtle social cues that
people exchange when they are communicating.
Your conversations will flow better with fewer awkward pauses.
This will make you more likely to meet people,
interact with them,
and impress them.
Doing so,
we'll not only genuinely increase the probability that good things will happen
to you.
It will also make those good things feel better when they do happen.
Thus strengthened and emboldened.
You may choose to embrace being and worked for its furtherance and improvement,
thus strengthened.
You may be able to stand even during the illness of a loved one,
even during the death of a parent,
and allow others to find strength alongside you when they would otherwise be
overwhelmed with the spare thus emboldened,
you will embark on the voyage of your life.
Let your light shine,
so to speak,
on the Heavenly Hill and pursue your rightful destiny.
Then the meeting of your life may be sufficient to keep the corrupting influence
of mortal disparate bay.
Then you may be able to accept the terrible burden of the world and find joy.
Look for your inspiration to the victorious lobster with its 350 million years
of practical wisdom.
Stand up straight with your shoulders back.